le christianisme le judaïsme de religion
longtemps ennemis et ça ne s'est pas
arrangée avec la shoah pour les
réconcilier il n'a fallu attendre le
pape jean paul ii et lui il y à 40 ans
dès son élection en 1978 jean paul ii
est attendu sur un point la condamnation
de la shoah la faute à pie xii pape
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale qui a
brillé par son silence sur la question
jean paul ii envoie un signal fort un an
après son élection dans sa pologne
natale
en 1979 il donne une messe devant le
mémorial d'auschwitz
jean paul ii a lancé dans son sermon un
appel solennel pour le respect des
droits de l'homme
auschwitz nous montre bien a dit le pape
avec quelle facilité
l'homme venait piétiner une ouverture
mais pas d' excuses pour autant les
relations entre le vatican et israël se
tissent petit à petit en 1994 le pape
reçoit le premier ministre israélien
itzhak rabin 46 ans après la fondation
d'israël
voilà qu'un chef de gouvernement de
l'état juif et reçus officiellement par
le pape
reconnaissant israël processus de paix
avec la palestine
voici les deux sujets entre le vatican
et l'état hébreu
leurs rapports vont franchir une étape 6
ans plus tard en 2000 lors du pèlerinage
du pape en 10 rennes jean paul ii a
lancé un appel au dialogue entre les
trois religions monothéistes
avant de conclure par un retentissant
les applaudissements néanmoins c'est un
voyage compliqué qui s'annonce
quand jean paul ii pénètre dans le
mémorial des victimes de la shoah
le 23 mars son attitude et ses mots sont
scrutés déplore silence parce qu'il n'y
a pas de mots assez forts pour déplorer
la tragédie de la shoah dit jean paul ii
émotions mais pas deux formules de
pardon ni de mention de pie xii et de
son silence coupable
pour cela il faut attendre trois jours
le 26 mars 2000 c'est sans doute l'image
que l'histoire retiendra de ce
pèlerinage en terre sainte une prière et
une lettre déposée sur le mur des
lamentations il y demande pardon à dieu
pardon pour les souffrances des juifs le
début de relations plus apaisées entre
judaïsme et christianisme
[Musique]